the question the community has is
does this work if you believe that it
does i'd like to hear you i know it does
this is elizabeth holmes
six years ago she was one of the most
celebrated ceos in silicon valley her
biotech startup theranos which promised
to revolutionize blood testing was once
valued at more than nine billion dollars
and forbes held her as the youngest
self-made female billionaire
but then theranos's well-crafted story
began to fall apart
just days before holmes took to the
stage at this 2015 conference the wall
street journal published two articles
that cast serious doubts on the
effectiveness of theranosis technology
do you feel now
in hindsight that maybe you went to
market a little too quickly we're the
exact same company that we were last
wednesday before these two articles were
published nothing has changed just
because some guy reports false stuff
about us doesn't mean that it changes
our business we knew she was blatantly
prevaricating and it's interesting that
the government has used many of the
facts that we uncovered in our stories
as a basis for the criminal complaint
that's now pending against elizabeth
today theronus has been dissolved and
holmes faces a federal indictment of 12
different charges two counts of
conspiracy to commit wire fraud and 10
counts of wire fraud the case has two
parts prosecutors allegedly defrauded
both investors who gave hundreds of
millions of dollars to theranos and also
patients who paid for tests now with our
trial about to begin on august 31st we
revisit theranos's story and holmes's
fall from grace to understand what we
can expect from a case that is shaping
up to be one of the biggest trials in
recent years
the woman who i will be interviewing
needs no introduction first they think
you're crazy then they fight you and
then all of a sudden you change the
world almost every media outlet
including us here at cbs bought into the
theranos myth breaking news right now
elizabeth holmes is stepping down as ceo
of theranos the theranos saga has been
one of silicon valley's biggest scandals
and as such it's attracted a lot of
attention to date the theranos story has
been chronicled in a best-selling book
an hbo documentary a podcast and two
still-to-come hollywood adaptations
before the journal stories elizabeth was
a darling of silicon valley she was
you know viewed as potentially the next
steve jobs theranos promised to
revolutionize blood testing with a new
technology that could diagnose
everything from cholesterol to hiv using
only a few drops of blood
we'd like to see a world in which every
person
gets access to this type of basic
testing from an early age elizabeth
holmes had aspirations to be an engineer
i first met her when she came to my
office
when she was a freshman at stanford and
i believe it was the fall of 2002.
in this deposition interview one of
holmes's earliest backers stanford
university professor channing robertson
recalled that by the next year holmes
had decided to drop out and launch
theranos she asked me if i would
be on her board and i said yes
holmes started theranos in 2003 after
dropping out as a 19 year old sophomore
over the next 12 years she raised
hundreds of millions from investors and
theranos's valuation ballooned to more
than 9 billion dollars
two former secretaries of state henry
kissinger and george schultz were
members of the board of directors and
how did you
first become involved with fairness
secretary schultz
mentioned
the company
that
he reached out
shortly
maybe several years after i left the
senate in this deposition taken in a
civil case brought by investors former
theranos board member and former senate
majority leader bill frist recalled the
first time he met elizabeth holmes they
had a
box there a machine there
and
told the history
of her individual history and of
the stage of the company at that point
uh
do
uh remember actually at that meeting
doing a finger prick
the technology and the results came back
at that meeting so you did test the
technology right at that first meeting
yes
and it was analyzed right there and then
yes and the results were given to you
yes right there and then investors like
the walton family and rupert murdoch
executive chairman of news corp the
journal's parent company each invested
over 100 million dollars others like
former education secretary betsy devos's
family invested 100 million dollars and
mexican tycoon carlos slim invested 30
million dollars
if this technology truly worked it could
have
upended the the entire blood testing
industry it could have made them a lot
of money but after the publication of
two wall street journal articles in
october 2015 holmes claims began to
unravel you're now at the point
where you're only testing
for one thing herpes
using your proprietary technology is
that correct
it's not correct
and there's a lot of different elements
of our work that have been con uh
conflated through these
two pieces the journal reported that
theranos wasn't using its own technology
for the vast majority of its tests and
was instead using commercially available
machines
the company's edison machine the lab
instrument touted as the linchpin of its
strategy handled just a small fraction
of tests that were sold to consumers and
former employees told the journal the
accuracy of edison's tests was poor
so if i went to one of the centers and i
got a pinprick
and i only gave that much blood
right what tests are you currently able
to perform for that blood
using anything other than
commercially available lab equipment so
we have never used commercially
available lab equipment
for finger stick based tests every
finger stick test that we have ever done
uses proprietary theranose technology
that is not commercially available well
it sounded great for her to say that
they
never used third party commercially
available
blood testing technology unfortunately
it's not grounded in facts in this 2018
deposition interview former theranose
product manager daniel edlund recalled a
company meeting in which the use of
third-party analyzers was discussed i
heard discussion
about
certain theranost tests being
lab developed tests
that were run on third-party machines
the 2016 journal article found that
theranos failed to maintain basic
safeguards to ensure consistent results
what's more because of the company's
many questionable tests some patients
adjusted the amount of medicine they
were taking others like breast cancer
survivor sherry eckert panicked as seen
here in this 2016 wall street journal
video when i went online and got the
results um i printed them off it looks
like they're normal and then i thought i
better go back and look at that again
okay what's the range the reference
range and i noticed that it's
for pre-menopausal women okay well
that's not me
eckert who could be called to testify in
the trial received blood test results
from theranos that showed estrogen
levels many times higher than is normal
for a postmenopausal woman her
oncologist told the journal the high
estrogen level could cause cancer to
recur or could be a sign of a rare tumor
either they
they made a mistake
they tested somebody else's blood or
their controls don't work or
i
have a tumor somewhere great the
patients were the pawns in all this many
of them who had gotten tests and the
tests seemed to be
wildly off
they would sometimes have repeated tests
at theranos and then when those were
were wildly off they would go to a
traditional you know quest or lab corps
when they complained oftentimes they
would not get any kind of a response you
have no
concerns about where you are today what
we've done for the last few days is
listen right and try to understand what
are the questions that the community has
and we've been preparing material to be
able to answer that for them because
that that matters hugely to me
at this event holmes promised to publish
data proving the accuracy of theranos's
more than 240 tests
but theranose was never able to provide
that data
the records of the millions of blood
tests that theron was performed were
stored on a database but in 2018
theronos employees dismantled the
servers containing the original database
meanwhile prosecutors didn't realize for
months that a copy they received was
missing a necessary encryption code
at this point neither the government nor
theronos or elizabeth holmes have access
to this database anymore kind of
extraordinary that it just sort of
disappeared
prosecutors believe that even without
the database a successful prosecution
can be carried out with the anecdotal
evidence available holmes defense team
has argued that without this database
and broader data prosecutors shouldn't
be able to call patients and doctors to
the stand who said they got inaccurate
test results so they've put a lot of
stake in this lost database prosecutors
first indicted holmes and former
theranos executive ramesh sani bahwani
in june 2018. holmes settled civil
charges filed by the sec in 2018.
prosecutors say that from 2010 to 2015
in investor pitches that elizabeth
holmes did she basically told investors
that they had this revolutionary
technology but they say that in reality
that wasn't true and she knew it
prosecutors say investors were told
theranos would generate over 100 million
dollars in revenue in 2014 and that
theranos had lucrative contracts with
the department of defense that didn't
exist
in the indictment prosecutors point to
six specific wire transfers from unnamed
investors that they say were the result
of allegedly fraudulent acts including a
nearly 100 million dollar deposit to a
theronos account sent in october 2014
intent is what matters and showing that
someone intended to deceive and so if
elizabeth holmes lawyers can say that
she
believed in the technology that could be
one line of defense elizabeth holmes
lawyers could also argue um that all
silicon valley startups embellished to
investors and that what theiranos did
was no different it's unclear if holmes
will testify in the trial or what the
defense's strategy will be
to me the most interesting element is
elizabeth holmes going to testify on her
own behalf i mean it's always the big
question and i tend to doubt it but you
know it's unclear we don't know that we
also don't know who definitively the
witnesses are going to be choosing an
impartial jury is expected to be a major
undertaking because of the substantial
coverage theranos has received i think
it could take a while and be an
intensive process to pick the jury
elizabeth holmes's side is very
concerned about finding jurors that
aren't already prejudiced against her
and the company holmes has pleaded not
guilty
each wire fraud count carries a maximum
prison sentence of 20 years
[Music]